[音楽]
me
ええええええ
皆さんこんにちは今日はお手元に折り紙が中配られているみたいなんですけども
最後に折り紙を折ったのはいつですか
覚えてますか
京都は言わないでくださいね今日はいっ
おいてないですよね
僕もねあの
子供の頃から折り紙折ったことないんですけども最近娘が折り紙夜の好きで起こってい
ます
そうすると子供の頃はなぁなんかところ夢中になって思ってたの
大人になってから折り紙を折るとなぜか何か新しい発見があります
でまずこちらこちらの折り紙も娘と一緒に陥っている時に気づいたんですけどもまだ
完成してませんねこれは何を追ってる途中でしょう
ています
あと
もう少しできます
ピントはひな祭り
わかる
そうそうそう動きなサビなさそうそうそう実はですね
こちら
この日だ人形ですね
ただですねこれを見てごらんになると
実はあの折り方からこの2つの女雛とお雛に分かれて完成できます
でこの時にですね私は娘と一緒に売ってました
その時に娘はは最初はあそこまでは私と一緒によっているのでまあまあねしてるんです
ね
でこの後に
彼女女雛をって私が女おるで時にですね彼女はすごくワクワクしたんです
なぜかというと
パパとは違う折り方で自分の女雛が折れるとこれをこのワクワクっていうの私に伝わっ
てきました
でその時にですね私も後になって冷静になって考えたんですけれどもこれは人生におい
て正よる分岐点っていうのはみなさんそれぞれあると思います
またこれがあると思います
まず分岐点というのは一つの道この道というのは自分が信じてたことあとは周囲に
合わせてたこと
まあその道を歩んでるんですけども突然
を別れるときは別れる時とひょうひょうとした自分の道を見つけた時ですね
その時にですね非常にわくわくします
私はですねこの娘とこのおりがみ折りながらまあ人生の分岐点というのを私なりに考え
てみました
私の人生の分岐点なんですけども
実は8テリー番組を7年間作っていて非常に高夢中になって作ってました
夢中になってるとですね非常に見過ごすことが多いですね
子供の頃はまあ環境に守られているのでその環境だが夢中になることというのは簡単な
んですけども
社会に出るといろいろ周りのプレッシャーだったりとかいろんな環境が変わるのでもう
一つのことに夢中になると非常に難しいですただ私はサブテレビ番組というの一つ
まあアルバイトから始めて正社員になってディレクターになって正
いわゆる自分のテレビを番組をつくってま視聴率も取れたらいいなーとかそういう目標
を持ってやって夢中になってきました
ただその時にまああの例えば結構のことを考えたりとか本当に番組とは関係ないことを
一切意識しないできましたその時ですね生活はですねだんだんマンネリ化しできます
これがもう
20代の後半ただただ番組をつくってっていつかは大きな番機を作りたいということ
だけでした
でその時にですね私はちょうど30歳になってある番組を作る時にある人に出会った
きっかけでちょっとの分岐点というのを見つけましたこれはですねあの浅草の8
コメディアンで前田リーンさんという人に出会ったのがきっかけです
おそらくこの中
ではご存知な方と思いませんがいると思う
わかんないなもうお父さんとおじいちゃんの時代ですね
あのいテレビであのートリオブームというのが起こったんですけど漫才の
その時にナンセンストリオって言う
グルーアート量がいてその中で1んだから1960年ぐらいにテレビで脚光を浴びた
8芸人さんですねその方がええとまぁもう68歳になって
で浅草でえっ舞台に立ってるところ私はを見つけてですね
2海に入ってで彼の4話を聞いていろんな話出てきました
一つはですね彼は
8章はの喜劇をと言われたさんへの鍵というのもと検知っていうの昔てるんですけれど
も彼のでしょうしてんだ
もう一つは今話したようにテレビに出た有名になった
でそれ以前にはですね浅草池袋とかいわゆる
浅草がエンタメの街ですごく朝書いてた頃を知っているの
久住ですね下積みしてた土で知っているということで私はその彼を通して一つ日本の
銃声
壱岐やる大衆系のの歴史番組を作ろうかなというふうに企画を考えました
いわゆる彼が歩んできた道をは彼の証言
いろんな時代をのですね
中で出会ったことやそういう証言を集めて番組を作ろうかなと思って
で記録あげました
でその時ですね8彼は舞台に上がっていた時はですねその浅草の演芸場といって昔は
ストリップ劇場で今でもあります
で彼はそこで毎日しトリをつとめているんですけどもお客さんを招待客だけですそれで
も68歳になってずっと舞台に立っていますでまぁへ
を彼はですねで私は不思議に思ってなんで今のもう有名にもなってこんな歳にもなって
失礼だけどもなんで二重立っているのかなで非常に疑問でした
で私はまあのいわゆる構成を考えて
でへと彼に取材の申し込みをしに行きました
その時にですね私はあの世大衆芸能今日本にも落語とかねまあテレビでものはああいう
コント以外にも色々歴史があるわけですね
そのことについて勉強しなかったんです
彼にそれを見破られました
で私はですねでもまあ客を成立させたい番組を作りたいというまあねついてどうにか
取材の許可をあおります
ってその時にですねでも構成というのを書かないといけないですね
構成というのはいわゆるガイドラインみたいなものですね
まあプロデューサー見せたりとかまあ曲 p に見せたりとかっていうことですね
まあそれで書くんですけども非常に私の知識が浅い
何も知らないのでしかもまあ証言だけで歴史を語るようなまぁちょっとつまらない子
構成そこでですね取材を始めるんですけれどもやはりですね彼は乗ってこないわけです
この密着取材で自分は過去を話したけど面白くないわけです
でもこれはですねよくありますディレクターでよく考えます
どうにか相手もノー整体でもですねそこでは私はですねこのマンネリ化
作り方のマンネリ化という
ところでドツボにはまっていて全然を持つカメラ思いつかなかったんですね
そこで彼はですね女子ビデオ決して浮き出して私ですねじゃあちょっと居酒屋に連れて
やるからこいと連れてきました
でその時にですね彼は駄作さの一件いざ改正でてくれて
へ行ったらそこにあの
食べにですねたくさんサインがあるんですねこのサインというのは全員その浅草からを
出て行ったり
活躍してたり今でも活躍して芸人さんたちのサインですもいっぱいあります
これを壁見ただけで歴史が分かるようなですね私はすごく喜びましたいいなぁと
ただその時ですね前田さんはいいましたあれは君はカメラを下しなサイト
でその時ですね彼後私はお酒方のみながらですね彼は自分の下積み時代
あとはその間にワザっているってこと今まで私がその校正段階でお知らなかったような
こと
まあカメラの前で証言では拾えなかったことを話してくれましたその時にですね私は
スーッと何かこう気持ちが
落ち着いてきて全く高生のことを考えずひたすらその前田さんっていう人にですね興味
を持ち始めました
そこで私の素直の質問はですねなんで前田さんは
浅草に戻ってきたのかと
これを投げかけましたすると前田さんは人は年をとると
楽しかった場所に戻りたくなるんだよという一言を言いました
これこのこの言葉はですね僕にすごく胸に響きました
っていうのは
その言葉ってまさしく自分がこの後将来
だにしていこうかなと果たして自分が年取ったときに楽しかった場所戻れる場所って
あるのかなということを考えましたですのどかですね私にはなかったですね
まあテレビもまあそれは限定ではないと思いますし
多分そこにはも損だと思いますでそこで
私はまあそういう気持ちでまあ彼が発する言葉を拾って胸にとどめました
でその時にですね私たち土工壁を見渡してみるとですね
そこにですねひとつだけ
サインの中に空白があるのです音が小さい空白
これはですね多分それまで来たお客様を見つけられなかったような場所にありました
ちょっと高いところですねでこれ私はそのまま前田さんのその話の要因でですね
ちょっと身についたわけですこれを店長に聞いてみるとあのこの空白っていうのはある
米
23から浅草を出ていた芸人さんが戻ってきた時にこう
帰ってもらうどこしてあるんだよって言われたんですね
3その時にですね私はこれいい話だなぁと
思いましたでこれをあの構成にはありませんでしたけれどもこれは前田さんのその話と
ともに紹介したいなぁと思いました
でこの時ですねもう私はもうこうすることは全く考えずにもう1回この映像素材を
見直していわゆる
何か発見かないかなというも気持ちでいっぱいでした
その時に見つけたのは嫌でも捨てた素材ですね必要のない素材にたくさんそ今の浅草と
前田さんの本いろんな姿が写ってるわけですねその時です私はもまあ今の倍ださんを
描こうと
っぽうカパの故障げなくはいらないということでも証言
実際せてもう今の前田さんだけでつないで一つの番組を作りました
あとはこの空白の壁の子がのいい話をですねその中で消化しました
まあこの時にですね私は気づいたのはまあ実はあの
物事にやるやる常に別の方法があるってことですね
って私は今までずっとその構成をつくって編集をしているということに信じてやってき
ました
これは多分おそらく
まあそのテレビ業界に貼られる方はわかると思いますけども一つマニュアルですね
でその中で私は見つけようと思っても実は見つからなかった
で3つかんだかとたかったことっていうのはなぜなにかというと自分の視点です
自分の姿勢が身につかなかったんですねってそこでですね私はもう1回まあ
とこのおりかけた折り紙を広げようと思って
新しい人生をもう一回限定を見つけを止めました
でその今までの8やってきたことを生かしててみようとで折り紙を広げるとたくさんの
この
折り目が残っていますこれはもう過去の出来事ですね
でもこの中で注目できるのは空白がたくさんあるということです私はですねまぁ本だけ
kuwa kuwa
なんだったらまあ思い切ってもっと新しいことをやろうということでいわゆる
もうテレビ業界を離れて新しいボタンを見つけようと思って中国に来ました
で中国がなぜかというとその時も2005年でぴ北京オリンピックのもうすでに3年前
非常に盛り上がっていますまあ世界の中心として世界
中から注目を浴びていましたまあその場でですね私もクハダでその時代の流れを感じて
みたい
新しいものを見つけたいということで中国に行きました
で行ってみて私はですねじゃあここで何お金取ろうかと思った時にですね
一つの疑問が湧きますそこで思ったのはやはりその時その中央個人というのはいわゆる
とには裕福になりたいということでまさにその完成形を求めてみんなが頑張ってる
ところに非常に日本のバブル時代で弾いてるんですけども
あの執着していわゆる今
カポ振り返ってみて
ことを忘れていたんですね私はそのまあ新しいピルができているところで端まではその
胡同という街が壊されていく
でそういう綺麗な花このでき是非御問合せの建物もパーされているということで
まったく見向きしないわけですねまぁその時に私は
チャーその今の中国の人たちが見過ごしていることを
人目を向けて
何かその映画にできないかとそれがまあ無意識に miomio 済みそうしている
ことを意識するということで
まあそれを映画にしようとっていうことで中国のそれが一つの目的になりました
でこちらです
でこれはでちょっと暗いですけどもまぁ卵と美味しいと言う
いまご荘櫂にあった映画こちらはですねえ留守児童
か性的虐待になる合うを少女がですね
でちょっと三国のストーリーです
このストーリーはですね実は私の中国人の妻が脚本で支えた時に過ごし発見しました
なぜかというと彼女自身その留守児童
なんですけどもって彼女はですねえっ8初めはその男の子と女の子の素顔はいてその
恋愛の話を書いていたんですけれども
彼女は
その中で一つだけその性的虐待ちょっと描写したようなリアルな発表したかったんです
ね
そこを脚本を読んだ時にあれこれなんでここだけすごいリアルなノート彼女に聞いたら
彼女は実は私の実体験だったと
っていうことを言いましたその実体験とは彼女はずっと私に出会うまで誰にも親にも
言わなかったことそれがですね
彼女はその脚本2と書き続けて誰かに分かってもらいたいのかな
そういうことでいわゆる
方
帰っていたわけですねその時にですね私はじゃあ
一度来ようとこの
えっここにスポットを当ててもうちょっと焦点をするとこれを描いしてみたらどうかと
いうことでへと提案しました
でその時にですねあの私たちはその中国の農村に入って今の少女たち
生態学虐待にあった小たちを取材しましたその時ですねえっ8可能の少女たちは
あのー一切口を閉ざしたまま言わないわけですね
そのかパソ事実というのも場合の周囲の大人たちがみんな言うんです
子どもたちは一切言わないで何が起こったか
では私もずっと妻もその光景を見て最後にその子供が私たちを見送りに来てくれる時も
ですね
その一緒に歩いて行くんですがその時も何も言いませんその時にですね私は気づいたの
は
ひょっとしたら私たちにもと気づいてほしかったんじゃないかなともっと何か話しかけ
ことがあったじゃないかなということを築き
ましたというのは
そういう訳被害にあった人たちというのは何かこの相談できる相手が欲しいわけですね
だから言えない
っていうことで私はと妻はそこで相談してじゃあこれは妻の経験実体験でもあります
けれどもこれは者映画にして
したらどうかと体がというのはですねやはり一つの役割としてはリンチつ社会で起こっ
て言って皆さんが見過ごしていることを日がにして
でそれを見た時にあ
なるほどとわかったりとか感動したりとかそういう学割はあると思うんですね
でそこで私たちはこれでは作ってみようという決心しました
操作とですね上映国際映画祭で上映したりするとやはりですね
何人が女性のお客さん中からあっあ勇気を与えてくれてありがとう
って私の代わりに口を開いてくれてありがとうっていう言葉が返ってきました
っていうのはそうやはり映画というのです1つ世に出ると一つ発見っていうのはやはり
ジャズ無意識のこと皆さん気づいていないことっていうのはどんどんわかってきます
これが一つのまあ映画の魅力でありですね映画の役割だと思うんですけれども
まあそういうことですね私はまあ
そういうことを考えてで次の何か現実社会でですね
現実の世界で見過ごしてることを見つけながらですね大にどんなテーマがあるかなと
いうことで
方を折ったり広げたりしながらします
でえええ
こちらポスターですねで
今ですね
今のこの折り紙の状態は
もしはがいっぱいあります
ってやはりですのでも空白ありますねで私もですね
あのもこれからの目標としてはまずこのおりガーデンで例えるとを持つ完成形をあまり
求めないで2つ目はですね
この
o-北地元でもう一つはたまに行くを広げてみて
この空白を見つけてここで何かもっと新しいことが見つけられないかなと見つける
これを今掘るに幌があります
で最後になりますけれども
実はですね先ほどの空白の壁ですね
壁の空白の話ですね続きがありましてその番組を放送した時ですね
この壁に気づいた人がいました
しかもそので
翌日にその店長から電話がかかってきてあれ大塚さん来たんだよーとついにできました
それが誰だと思いますか
これ浅草出身です
てその壁を見た方はですねビートたけしさんでした
エソ下がりに北野たけしとこう言ってみると書いたのです
まあこれもまあ皆さんも私も全然予想もつかなかった展開だったんですけどもまぁその
後の展開としてですね
まあ皆さんにはその批判の剛士さんからですね映画の大幅でありました
っていうなぜかというと彼らはやるちょっと年配で前田さんが
でえっと p 度高さちょうど後輩なんですね
まあそういったやりたい
の支持台で巡り合った2人っていうのはコレ
まあてくれあったわけですねってことでこれは私の正
だした人生の折々目であります皆さんもぜひ見つけてください
はい
います
[拍手]